Reste dehors. Reste dehors on veut te parler.
Mets les mains dans les airs. Les mains dans les air s'il te plait.
Garde tes mains dans les airs s'il te plait.
On n'est pas là pour te faire du mal. On veut juste que tu collabores. Mais il faut qu'on te parles. »
Je sais qu'il fait froid. On va t'aider, OK? Garde tes mains dans les airs, s'il te plait.
Moi, j’ai fait plus de 20 ans de patrouille dans un véhicule patrouille.
Et je ne peux pas compter le nombre de fois où j’ai répondu à des familles inquiètes :
"Oui, mais là, il n’est rien arrivé et je ne peux rien faire pour vous."
Moi, mon plan, c'est qu'on l'appelle. Et qu'on lui demande de sortir.
Vous autres, vous allez aller côté 6 heures.
Là ce que vous avez vu, c'est l'exemple d'un dossier et on en a au-dessus de 1000 par année seulement à notre service.
Il y a deux ans, l'analyse qu'on en avait fait, c'était entre 9 et 12 appels par jour.
On a raison de croire que le chiffre a augmenté parce que lorsqu'on questionne nos patrouilleurs,
ils disent qu'ils en ont davantage qu'auparavant. On peut même imaginer que le chiffre de 12 est conservateur.